hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for
Monday October 23rd
2023 what's going on how are
you how's it
going Jesus Christ it's the holiday
season I I should have already started
my [__] Christmas Sho and I said well
first of all morning good morning
everybody before I start going off here
before I start flipping out let me let
me let you get a [__] sip of your
coffee you know or maybe you're driving
down the
street you're some beat down [__]
person you know one of those people that
wears a raincoat every day but you're
not a
pervert it's just like part of your
mood like that Columbo guy just always
walking around all
schlubby on your way to
work you know letting people in that's a
great way that's a great way to get home
and go to work just let people in go
ahead you in [__] patient bastard God
bless
you did that get you five seconds closer
to that thing you don't even want to
do why are you trying to be early to
something you don't want to
do would you like to go in front of me
fantastic I'll get to work 8 seconds
later and that's eight less seconds I
have to listen to every [__] idiot
that I work with that's one way of
looking at
it you know that's kind of how I deal
with LA traffic I just I just put on
some [__] relaxing music and I just
let everybody
go oh go ahead good Ahad there you go no
no no no no no that's fine it's fine go
ahead you
go you you [__]
compete I tapped out I'm I'm I'm driving
I'm I'm playing for a [__] number one
draft pick next season there's that kid
coming out of UFC that's what I'm that's
what this franchise is going
for
um yeah I actually uh was looking at I'm
trying to figure out some gifts they're
kind of like
uh
like different like last year was easy I
think five and two is easier than six
and three cuz they're both like you
know my son's like almost
like he's not a toddler he's just like a
little boy but when he's four he's going
to be a
boy and then my daughter is a like going
to be like I feel like once you're like
seven you're kind of like a big girl
before is that is that what happens
before like a teenager I don't [__]
hell this is my first time doing it so
it's kind of
like you know she she's kind of getting
too old for toys but all like the
electronics she wants it's like I'm not
getting you that
[__] you know you're not going on the
internet have all these [__] weirdos
you that's not
happening and then my son it's just like
everything that I want to get
him he's not quite developed enough for
like they put out a new Green Machine by
the way and the green machine for you
younger kids out there they had the big
wheel so you know
yeah work show always have to top it
right so then they come out with the
[__] uh they came out with the green
machine so not only could you come
screaming down the hill in this plastic
piece of [__] you could they had like
two handles or something I forget how it
worked all I know is you you like pulled
one of them you can do like a fish or
was that was y one the the the
uh the big wheel after a while came with
like a little handbrake on one of the
wheels and you'd pull that thing and
when you were going fast enough it's
what you got your first separated
shoulder and concussion as you launched
yourself off the [__]
thing
um yeah there was a lot of that growing
up there was a lot of like getting
[__] up with like toys and stuff
although I do find it funny that my
generation talks the the amount of [__]
that they told like this was what
childhood used like we're acting like we
fought a we didn't even fight a war
right we were in between
Vietnam and the Gulf War [__] you know
other than that that like you know very
few people from my generation were
involved in
that that that that 10day war in like
was it '
91 but other than that like you know
there was no
draft there was nothing there was
nothing
like happening if you grew up in the
suburbs like most of us did I don't know
what the [__] they're talking about uh
um and what every generation says back
when I was a kid it was great and what
it is it's it's cuz you were young and
there was no stress there was no divorce
there was no taxes there was no nothing
of course it was [__] great anytime
was great unless you were born during
wartime and people were [__] bombing
your country then then it sucks other
than that yeah every decade's great if
you're
seven I would think so you know I went
to a uh I went to an unbelievable
[__] wedding this weekend and
um and like this one of these towns like
you can't even believe it exists like
the amount of [__] that California gets
from people who've never been here I'm
not saying to live here cuz they do tax
the [__] out of you but everybody
thinking that people are walking around
with interchangeable parts and every
other weekend they're becoming a
different sex or whatever the [__] you
think is going on out here that's not
what's going on out here I this is a
[__] great place to come out to
um like all states are every state
there's something great to do um as far
as like uh like sleepy little town wine
wineries and all of that
stuff um in between like LA and San
Diego and la and and uh what would you
call San Francisco and then North of San
Francisco there's so many these these
fraking places if you're like married
you're looking to go do something with
your wife where you can actually have a
good time too and kind of get you know
and she's out boozing drinking wine so
she's not going to get on you whatever
your thing is you know cigars
smack like honey you doing heroin yeah I
mean isn't that like your second bottle
of wine I mean we're on vacation we're
on
vacation heroin would be [__] amazing
if it wasn't addictive if you just could
like do it and then just like walk away
from
it they ever dad done like an like
anybody ever been able to do
that it just seems like it's
like it's like flying first class like
once you do it you can never go
back I can't sit back there
again I don't want to do I mean you
could do
it that's the scary I think that that's
what like why I would never try heroin
CU I feel like once you're cleaned up
like the rest of your life you just feel
like you're flying coach
and no matter how good the cup of coffee
is no matter how good the sandwich is
it's just Never As Good As that first
time you [__] knotted off in a street
corner and almost got hit by a
bus
um [__] evil drug man that [__] was
out of control when I was a kid when I
first came down to New York City man
they used to be people just
[__] I mean half half
the half the comedians in the city had a
bit imitating a [__] junkie noding
off and everybody like laughing knowing
exactly what they meant you know they
were people like you look at them and
you just be like man when you sober up
your back or your legs are going to be
so [__] [__] up and the joke with
all the comedians was is that the
junkies never fell down they never would
fall
down it was like this
this I I don't know how long a high on
heroin last but it was
um I remember seeing this one [__]
guy like it was one of the coldest days
I could remember in New York and he was
standing there he had a [__] t-shirt
jeans on and sneakers with no socks and
everyone was waiting across the street
just freezing their asses off and
whatever he was looking at that he could
see he was laughing his [__] ass off
like tears coming down his face he was
laughing so [__] hard he was laughing
so hard I started laughing and the guy
didn't have a [__] coat
on I was just like dude I didn't want to
know I didn't want to [__] know what
you're
on
um by the way somebody sent me this
another [__] video of a goddamn shark
attack
where someone gets killed you can't
believe it it's like one of the most
horrific things I've
seen and the comment section
people are like going why did you swim
away from
it you you got to swim at it and [__]
then you can push it
away it's like what the [__] are you
talking
about is that what you did when when a
tiger shark came at you on your [__]
vacation you know what I would have
done first of all you swimming along and
all of a sudden something takes a bite
out of you you're going to freak
out right Splash around like what the
[__] then you're going to have to have
that moment of like is this really
happening to me you're going to be in
shock and everybody else is like okay
when that happens what you do is you
remain calm you simply swim like what do
you mean swim at the shark where is the
shark is it waving at you after it bites
you and then swims away and it's under
the water and you're just swimming on
the surface you don't have a [__]
snorkel and it's salt [__] water
exactly how are you supposed to
determine where this [__] thing
is
um I don't know dude you guys who swim
in the [__] ocean are out of your
godamn minds out of your [__] minds I
know the odds of it are really [__]
low but like the amount of [__] I get
for like
flying by people that will go to the
beach be is just like I think we've both
basically picked our
poison all right so I I I I don't need
to [__] hear it from
you
um so anyway
uh I went up with this wedding we were
up there for a couple of days and
uh had a great time you know hanging
with the lovely
Nia and
um I don't know I go back and forth with
those those sleepy towns up there
sometimes I feel like I could live up
there I always feel that and then other
times I feel like I would go out of my
[__] mind and then other times it's
like all right I think I'd go up there
and I'd like it then I'd go out of my
mind and then I would get used to it and
then I'd never be able to live in a city
again cuz it looks
amazing you know some of these places
you go to they don't they don't even let
like chain stores and oh there's very
few of them
anyway it's all kind of like Mom and Pop
[__] place places and [__]
um you know and you get a couple of
[__] lunatics you know those people
with their politics and their front
yard I love those
people it's like who who do you
think those are like the same people who
are going like celebrities should just
shut the [__] up with their political
opinions which I agree with unless
you're just going conspiracy theory I'm
all in if you just want to say
corporations own both parties I I can
listen to that [__] day uh but I
don't want to listen to this this side's
good and that side's bad that's like
[__] [__] talk but like the same
people who are saying that I mean do do
you say it to your
neighbor you
know I like the people who just like
around election times will just have a
sign up vote no on proposition
two it's like
okay I don't know what that is I don't
know who you are but thank you you for
the [__] advice what what else should
I
do what else should I vote
for um whatever why am I [__] on
they they're trying to they're
politically
active God that's got to be a [__]
major red flag if you're back out there
dating I'm politically active um anyway
yeah sometimes I think about that like I
saw
um you guys like going on like [__]
Real
Estate websites and just looking at
ridiculous [__]
places you know what I end up looking at
I always look at like
Farms you know I always look at like
having like a barn I can have my like
my Ford trucks out
there little podcast
Studio then I always think all right and
then i' record a podcast i' drive my
truck around town and I would put it
away and then what the [__] would I do
but then I think well what the [__] am I
doing now living in a city I don't
really do anything I try to avoid
people I don't know I think if you don't
grow up in the middle of nowhere like I
I think that's a real hard that's
probably the same thing like if you grow
up in the middle of nowhere which really
every every place is the middle of
nowhere like do I live somewhere because
there's a [__] movie theater close by
[Music]
hey look at me I'm living somewhere you
know look at that is that a Walmart yes
it is I can see that from my back
porch I have I am living somewhere I
think if you live in the middle of
nowhere though and if you came to the
city you have to be looking at people
like you got to be out of your [__]
mind why would anyone live like this and
sit in this [__] traffic and have to
come like come up with a strategy the
mindset to just get home you know I
think we both look at it that way it's a
typical [__] and then they're in the
middle of nowhere and they think we're
all [__] [__] in the cities and
every in the city thinks everybody's out
in the country you know [__] a yak
whatever the hell we say um anyway I
don't know I'm talking about I didn't
even I I caught like [__] 10 minutes
of um the Dolphins Eagles
game um I missed all the football this
week two weeks in a row I missed the
football and I gotta tell you it's
affecting my gambling
it's affecting my gambling in a big
goddamn way what the [__] is going on
with my phone you [__] what what is
going on here there we go
um right now I pick four games a week I
have yet to have a losing week I've only
had one winning week every week I've
gone two and two one week I went three
in one so it's two games above
500 um as of right now I am 0 and3 and I
got the Viking on Monday
night I'm not like against the 49ers I
don't know what I was thinking so many
underdogs won this week except for the
ones that I
picked I was impressed with the Arizona
Cardinals last week against the [__]
Rams right so I'm like all right they'll
go up there they're getting points
against Seattle Seattle's a you know a
little touch and go all right I like
this kid that the Cardinals have they
get [__]
smoked I'm like all right the Rams kind
of had a problem with the Cardinals I
bet they coach had them buckled down
Steelers are pretty erratic I'll take
the Rams [__] lose that one [__]
[__] Steelers I bet on you you lose I
bet against you you win [__] them you
get like that at this point by the time
you get into October there's just teams
you want no [__] part of Pittsburgh
Steelers [__] them these are this is my
I'm in my top three [__] them list the
Colts [__]
them and then the whole NFC
South cuz I don't have time I don't even
know what's going on down there but [__]
all that I don't know what Atlanta's
going to do from week to week I don't
know what the
[__] Saints are going to do I'm
staying away from the goddamn Panthers
because they're going to upset
somebody and Tampa you never know Baker
Mayfield will keep you in the game but I
don't know what the [__] going on down
there so I stay away from all of that
[__] those are my three right there [__]
the Steelers not saying literally the
team I just mean betting on
them and
uh [__] I should have take the Pats
man I'm just happy we won you
know Bill belch has never lost three in
a row since he's he finally that [__]
happen I didn't want to see four in a
row so
uh you
know I don't know it's a weird AFC East
is a [__] weird division this year
there's been like nine different
storylines that everybody thought okay
this is what's going to happen and none
of them have happened
so I don't even know uh and I don't even
think
like anybody's even worried about
anybody in the AFC East anymore
challenging the Kansas City Chiefs to go
to the Super Bowl I'd have to say now
it's maybe the the
Ravens I don't know I don't know I don't
it's a weird [__] year this parody
and this entertainment
League that is in business with Vegas I
I will never get over that that they
just all of a sudden did that but I
guess I should I should should expect
it you know it's the [__] NFL they're
a corporation they can't they just
cannot make enough [__] money they
can't do it you know they already find
out that [__] football causes CTE did
they give a [__] no they added another
game they don't give a [__] give us your
[__]
money you
[__] um
anyway so um I got Reno coming up this
weekend everybody
Reno one of my favorite
towns um really looking forward to that
I'm working with Joe
bartnik who has an unbelievable special
a killing in
Chicago uh you got to check it out
especially the intro which is was
totally Joe
bartnik idea and it was directed by Ben
tishler my writing partner that I worked
with on a
project that I'm not allowed to talk
about um yeah that's it all right let me
do the uh let me do the [__] reads
here I don't know how long this podcast
is going to be oh you know what I didn't
even talk about getting in
shape all right I I am I am I am
trying I I can do six Pull-Ups now
they're not pretty but I'm getting it
back
uh and I can get that [__] green
shirt on that I was telling you about
still AB seven and
eight they're just not there yet they're
just they're under Rubble an avalanche
of [__] bad decisions over the last
couple of years that I have to [__]
elliptical protein and lift weights my
way out of and uh I lost my eenth pair
of sunglasses this year sunglasses and
umbrellas they should just be comp M you
know just laying around you just take
whatever and [__] leave whatever like
you know those little things in the
neighborhood you know you got those
things where you can just drop a book in
take a book leave a book take a
book just walk past it no one gives a
[__] I don't know isn't that what
communism was supposed to be somehow
that didn't
work there a lot of people [__] on
capitalism right now how always loving
people [__] on capitalism it's like okay
what's your former government let me
guess that's working it's run by people
it's not going to work it's just not
going to work it's really not the form
of government that's not the problem
it's the
people um anyway
um all right let's let's do the read
here oh look who it is everybody it's
old
zip
recruiter right now I'd like to give a
shout out to all those people whose job
it is to hire from the small business
owner growing their team to the HR
directors hiring hundreds Across the
Nation you have one of the toughest jobs
there
is I mean you're going a little big
there one of the toughest jobs there is
you want to be a firefighter in [__]
California you want to try to hire
people although I will tell you there
are times you know I would imagine in a
job interview listening to somebody say
their life story and you already know
you're not going to [__] hire them
you're like oh God how do I and they
just keep going and you're just like
when can I interrupt this to end
it oh [__] that happened to me at the
wedding I ran to this person the guy
said hey I'm not a Celtics fan but I'm a
big fan of your
comedy I said well the Celtics don't
need you to be a fan they they've won 17
championships without you rooting for
them so what are you a Lakers fan and he
goes yeah I go what's that like buying
up the league every other [__] year
he goes yeah he goes yeah that's brutal
he he goes you know me and my dad and I
just looked at him I go this
conversation's
[Music]
over and I only did it cuz it was
somebody else standing there and the
other dude laughed and then the dude I
said it to just went like yeah he just
walked
[Laughter]
away oh try that out this week try that
out on that [__] you know the guy was a
nice guy I was just [__] with
him it was just really I had to go I you
know I had to go take a leak so I just
didn't want to I didn't want to [__]
listen to you and your dad's stories I
don't I don't want to hear it I don't
care um this conversation's over all
right what am I doing here I'm selling
zip recruiter uh but what if I were to
tell you that there's something that can
make your whole hiring process faster
and
easier OH
ZIP and right now you can try it for
free at ziprecruiter.com
because you've got a busy schedule
zip saves you time and
money smart technology finds and sends
you available great matches for your job
why don't they do that with like
politicians why can't you have like you
know this person's actually a caring
empathetic person who doesn't believe in
war or one person at the top taking all
the money and throwing Nickels at the
rest of the population why why can't we
do that with leaders um once you review
your list of the most qualified
candidates for your job you can easily
invite your top choices to apply so
they're more likely to apply sooner
Hiring Heroes let zip recruiter help
make your job easier what does that mean
Hiring
Heroes somebody [__] save a cat from
a tree are we talking about
veterans isn't everybody a hero we need
to normalize the word
hero I love people we need to normalize
oh that means you're not good enough so
you want to [__] lower the standard
four to five employers who post on
zip get a quality candidate within the
first day hey you don't believe me well
go [__] go [__]
yourself we haven't earned some trust
here can see for yourself go to this
exclusive web address and try it for
yourself uh for free at ziprecruiter.com
bur again that's
zip recruit that was the ocean liner
version of it ziprecruiter.com spell out
bur B RR Z recruiter the smartest way to
hire don't hire the dumb
way H the [__] smart
way
um I got a get on [__] stage this
week man I got some [__] I want to
[__] talk about man um well let's see
what you guys want to talk about Bill
great
emails let's see here big fan from
Brazil does that mean you're
fat and you're from Brazil or you're a
big fan of
mine fat Fan from Brazil fat [__] fan
hi Bill how are you I'm from Brazil and
I would love love to see you here in the
future I'd love to go down there go down
there for a F1 or Moto GP
race uh once I heard you talking about
on the Monday Morning podcast about
Brazil specifically about Rio de Janeiro
and what you knew about my country
unfortunately some
information are not wrong I was hoping
going to tell me I was
wrong uh when
girls slh is
he spelled it h o RS who is see Gringos
they will try to get money from selling
their
bodies yeah that they ain't going to get
anything from me I am not going to
another [__] Hemisphere and sticking
my dick in
something even if I wasn't married I'm
not doing that
okay that ship has sailed all right old
[__] Billy Freckle dick is standing
down if you know what I mean and Rio de
Janeiro is a very tourist City you will
encounter a lot of this now cuz I'd go
down there with my wife and that would
be all right uh but I really want you to
know the rest of the country I'm from
the
south Kur kurba and is a great City and
it's nothing like
Rio uh but don't you have like Nazis in
their 90s hiding out down
there I'm kidding not really uh Brazil
is a very big country with so many
different cultures that I think you
would love to know I would love to know
that I would love to know what a Nazi
felt like after he escaped and went down
to Brazil and saw how absolutely
gorgeous those people were and how they
didn't fit into that ugly [__] troll
Adolf Hitler's plan I wonder if any of
them sat there and was like what in the
[__] did we just
do what did we
do why would we get rid
of why would we get rid well first why
would you do that but you know you know
only kill the ugly
people what am I talking about when I
hear you I'm shallow when I hear you
speaking about Formula 1 and how you
like to know history and legends I
recommend you do a search
about I don't know arton Senna Well I
obviously every he's transcended the
sport I saw a whole thing on him there
was a great short documentary about him
on YouTube
uh Top Gear oh Top Gear that [__]
[__] from England always [__] on
Americans I love that guy cuz Americans
are so stupid oh yeah what are English
people
smart when you walk down the you walk
down the street in England that's what
you see is
intelligence [__]
guy um saying that we're dumb because
over here on our cars they like write it
out they have like the word what it is
you know over here here we just have a
picture uh I think it's easier to look
at a picture than actually read isn't it
I me you're literally talking about
literacy here like that one of the
dumbest points I've ever heard in my
life um that guy has like a major
[__] issue I don't know what it is he
just always goes every like every I
don't you can go one show without it's
like I get it you don't like America you
don't like American cars you think we're
dumb we get it you know like how how
much balls does that take to do in your
country
I [__] hate people why don't you [__]
on your own [__] country and see if
you can keep [__] your viewership
up [__] old
[__] um with [__] taste in cars by the
way uh anyway love the podcast and go
[__] yourself
um I would love to you know I'm actually
toying toying with the idea of doing a
tour down there next
year um I don't know how much I'll get
to see but I mean from what I've seen of
South America it just looks like a
paradise um gorgeous gorgeous continent
so I mean the [__] you only live once
why not go down there um
but I would like I wish I knew somebody
down
there you know I don't like going down
just like as a total tourist like I like
knowing somebody so they can so I don't
end up in the Time Square of Brazil
you know what I mean am I going to be
yet another jerk off hiking up to the
Jesus figure up top and taking my fix a
picture doing the the [__] peace
sign uh I kind of like the way the Jesus
is standing up there right the
Jesus um is he doing the thing like he's
on the cross or he kind of have his
hands out to the I like hands out to the
side like what the [__] are you
doing anyway um all right Bill how do
you win an argument with a
woman uh well first things first you
have to be right this is just to have a
you
know a chance and it's not because
they're better at arguing it's just like
they just you know they just keep going
and they start [__] being babies and
[__] so it's just like you just at some
point you're just like what am I doing
all right you're
right um all right greeting bill blumin
bur I'm a lesbian and I've been married
for seven I you know what I give
up all right please tell okay I hope you
giv me advice if you're a lesbian and
you can't win an argument with a a woman
there's no hope for us so please tell
me please tell me you have the solution
the answer to your question okay I'm a
lesbian and I've been married for 7even
years oh [__] here we go the answer to
your question is which is how do you
want and argue with a women a woman she
says you
don't okay that is a hardcore truth she
goes on to elaborate if you are the
Butcher of the
two and the bread
winner uh you are essentially the man
and you get [__] on like a
man
wow oh my God I love my wife but I will
never win an argument ever even with the
most logical and rational talking points
presented to her I don't win so you're
arguing logic yeah well I can tell you
that that sound I mean In fairness to
them it's our version of
logic um she argues with emotion and I
don't and I don't emotion beats
logic I would actually say emotion wears
out logic
her favorite thing to tell me is just
hug me and love me anyway there you have
it argument over just accept it go [__]
yourself well I would
say that you've reached a level of
Enlightenment you know what I mean you
can't tell
me that you don't have some other
lesbian that you you can then that's in
your situation that you don't call up
and then vent to
because that's what guys
do you know when I'm going through it
you know I got my buddy that I call up
you know I call up my buddy
verzy and I it
just what is what do we always
say it always it starts with the same
[__] line just like
uh you know one guy says is it is it
ever enough and the other one just goes
no
never
just like what
happened what happened um well I'll tell
you this there is a way to beat them
okay what it is is you can't argue with
them all right if if you're wrong I
stand by this if you're wrong you
apologize that builds up credibility if
you're
right you explain your position they
come back at you you explain your
position again they come back at you
again you just say all right fine fine I
don't want to argue
okay and then the ball is actually in
your court because they'll do one of two
things they'll either walk away at that
point or they just come at you and they
go well no we we should like discuss
this and blah blah blah and then you
just go look we discussed it you don't
agree with me I don't agree with you I
don't want to argue let's just forget it
all right and then if they say okay then
for the rest of the day you're just sort
of like there
I'm telling you this [__] works
you're not happy you're not mad you're
not excited you're not sad you're just
there you're participating in
conversation but you're not really
adding to
it and I'm going to tell you something
they know from the second you start
doing that [__] they know why you're
doing it so then they're going to go
through a couple hour period of
pretending like they don't know what's
going on and then eventually they're
going to ask you what the problem
is at which point you just say nothing
there's no
problem there's no no there's no problem
it's kind of seems like there's a
problem all
right and then finally they'll just own
up what are you still mad because ofah
blah blah
blah and you be like just be like I'm
not mad I'm
just you know
disappointed
and then eventually they come around
that's the only way but you have to go
you have to be willing it has to be
worth going through 3 hours to 3 days of
that [__] [__] and the problem is
is if you're logical you understand how
short life is and it isn't [__] worth
it and then what you do at that point is
you basically spoil the
child but I appreciate and I I empathize
I understand with what you're saying but
I'm telling you if you if there's
something you really want to win just
try the silent thing try the silent
thing and then [__] come back to me
and let me know how it works and uh if
there's any other lesbians out there you
want to write in I want to hear from
you there's got to be a lesbian out
there that's figured it
out um All Right Touch a
Truck dear
Bill touch a truck okay on your most
recent podcast you mentioned how much
your son is interested in buses police
cars trucks Etc and how he always talks
about how he wants to drive them I'm not
sure exactly where you live but in many
SI cities people organize events called
Touch a Truck where all the vehicles he
loves Gather in one area for kids to
climb on get inside or get behind the
wheel can I ask you a question who is
the person that named it that
touch
a touch a
truck you should never have touch and
kids and adults all in the same [__]
it's just it's just something creepy
about that um what else would you call
it Bill get in a truck that sounds like
kidnapping all right it's a tough
[__] sell I get what you're saying I
like
this I will say I'm a little weirded out
by the [__] name um my kids love
going to them and I'll bet it would be a
great way to spend a day with your son
just wanted to give you the heads up and
say thanks for all the great standup and
podcasts oh thank you well I'll say
um I stumbled upon one of those
accidentally one time and uh I was
taking them out to get the kids out to
get ice cream and I pulled up and there
was all of these fire
engines and a couple of like uh T other
Town trucks you know thing with the
bucket you know to go fix the telephone
pole [__] and my kids like freaked out
they had like the best time and that
thing so I will look up Touch a
Truck as long as it's just a truck um
all right don't want a corporate job
what's going on uh oh don't want a
corporate job what's going on old Billy
advice I'm a 19-year-old college student
and I'm caught between getting a
corporate job and trying standup
um however with everything being
recorded now I don't want to say
anything that would negatively impact my
chances of getting a job in the future
if comedy does not work for me I feel
like it's a huge risk you came up in a
Mickey Mouse era of Comedy where if you
said something bad in the
80s uh just starting out you could move
on with your life what are your thoughts
um I'm interested why you called it a
Mickey Mouse
era
um there was some there was certain
areas that area was better but as far as
like
people finding out who you were the only
way you could do that was you had to get
on TV and there wasn't a lot of
opportunities so there was there was
there was good and bad but I was
definitely uh
you know I I I will be honest with you I
I don't think anything that you say in
this standup world is going to [__]
prevent
you I I I mean from getting what [__]
job like what job are you going
for where if you're on stage going like
you know what the [__] is with people
with their cell phones filming
everything ba I mean what do you plan on
saying look if you go up there and
you're just like overtly [__] racist
or something I would yeah I would
imagine you know you can't run for
public office but
uh that's a kind of an amazing thing
that you're between a corporate job and
trying
standup are are are you conflicted on uh
my my simple question is what is your
dream do that if your dreams to have a
steady corporate job I would do that if
your dreams
try and stand up I would definitely do
that
like never try and stand up because
you're worried that it's not going to
work out and it will affect your
corporate position is is that's not a
good way to look at it you know and also
like the fact that you called like when
I came up a Mickey Mouse era that made
me laugh and you're kind of ball
breaking so you seem like you're funny
to me and uh I can tell you this a for
me anyway as [__] standup
job is is way more
fun than a corporate job comedians don't
hire corporations to come in and
entertain them it's the other way
around you know they they need
entertainment my job is entertaining as
much as I'm working I like I'm am
almost yeah I'm I'm I'm closer to 32
years and 31 years in this and I'm
loving and I'm having more fun than I've
ever [__]
had um and believe me there's a lot of
[__] that I can say on stage that could
affect you know
allegedly you know other
areas in my business it doesn't just
aect I mean my business is also
corporate when you know when you get in
business with like a studio or something
that's that's a [__]
Corporation and you know you can say the
wrong thing and and but I never think
that
I just think the wrong thing is not
saying and doing what you want to
do this
whole you know I I
like whatever you do with your
life I I like I avoid getting into
situations that if you say how you're
feeling that's going to O you know
overtly affect advertently ad
adversely overtly Jesus Christ adversely
affect like your career like then why
the [__] would you want to be and then
listen I understand every job has
parameters you know what I mean you
can't be a lawyer and going out like hey
I like doing blowing uh [__] hookers
you know filming myself and putting it
on my Facebook
page um my Tik Tok [__] toally Woodly
page whatever right I obviously
understand you can't Fu there's
parameters everything there parameters
what the [__] I do like as much as I go
on stage and act like a dick I don't
want to hurt anybody I'm not trying to
like [__]
you
know spread ignorance or anything
although some people would say that I do
I don't know you know I I but I
also I don't know it's kind of a tough
one for me to answer but like you're 19
years
old okay any stupid ass country uh
company that is going to hold what you
said at
19 you know against you like uh
I even feel like that's going away it
doesn't even [__] make sense I'm 55
years old I can't even remember what I
thought when I was
19 all right and I'll tell you I am a
different person at 55 than I was at 50
I'm way different I never tried
mushrooms I like I figured myself out as
far as like what the [__] is wrong with
me just within the last 5 years I'm
hoping with you you figure out now or
whatever but I I wouldn't
uh I don't know I I I I think you should
try it you seem funny you came up in a
Mickey Mouse era of Comedy where if you
said something bad in the 80s just
starting out you could move on with your
life that's funny to me I don't know
anyway the person goes on says are all
comics when they were younger the
equivalent of the kid throwing 90 miles
per hour as a 13-year-old or dunking
parenthesis at being funny look at that
that's a great analogy you're a smart
person if that's the case maybe I should
focus on a corporate job good and you
have low self-esteem I mean you you got
you have the whole [__] recipe here
you're funny you're making great
analogies and then you're [__] on
yourself
um if you came out of the gate and
you're just like I'm I'm one of the
funniest [__] people you ever going
to meet I'm like this guy's a hacker and
he might end up stealing jokes that's
what I would think but I'm not getting
that I'm getting I'm getting strong
standup comedian vibes from you and
um those stupid ass corporate jobs are
always going to [__] be there and I
can tell you one thing I don't think
I've never met somebody that has a
corporate job that loves the [__]
job you know they like the money they
like the
perks but I I don't think that anybody
I've ever met is just like
unless they're just after
money like I don't understand what the
satisfaction
is in well I'm [__] painting with the
broad brush here you know what I mean
like these [__] people that like they
go into a corporation in the job you
know I'm going to save this Corporation
money and they [__] fire a bunch of
people and then tell everybody who's
left do all the work that was being
being done by 100 people now with 25
people and then all the money that they
save they then give to themselves as a
bonus and then they walk away and they
can actually feel good about themselves
those people are [__]
lunatics
um whatever I don't know if this is this
a this is a man or a woman but I I think
you I definitely think you should try
you're also [__] 19 you're young it's
great time to to try it out you know
just think you know I didn't start until
I was almost 24 you'll have almost 5
years on me how much better you're going
to be than I was at that that age and
look where the [__] I got you
know um I I definitely think you should
go for I believe in you how about that I
believe in you going out and taking a
[__] chance all right there you go
all right well the podcast is a little
short this week uh I don't know what to
talk about because uh you know uh I have
some things going on in my life that I'm
just with this strike I'm not allowed to
talk about so um might be it's a little
uh it's a little short this week that's
what she said am I the only one still
left that still does that what she
that's what she said me and the lovely
Nia do it all the time and we we we it's
such a stupid joke we still think it's
funny you know you know and that's like
the kind of thing that you need in a
relationship you have to have your own
jokes that's the part where Oprah just
goes I like that you guys yeah she need
that let's build a show around that or
you just write a book about that you
have to have your own jokes yeah and
then every in the crowd's like yeah and
then the book comes out and everybody
reads it yeah
[Laughter]
yeah I really think Oprah if she wanted
to there was a moment there where she
could have taken over the
world she would just be like you know 40
is the new yeah I'm 40 now 40 is a new
30 yeah yeah 40's hot
yeah whatever she said I don't like
hamburgers I should need those yeah no
no just next you know all these steer
farmers were like suing her she had so
much [__]
power that's a
[__] an unbelievable audience that
she
had just people at home at that time of
day when she didn't she used to come on
at like
4:00 like what is that
crowd that's not the crowd that's that's
watching
in the morning CU I remember I used to
go on I never figured out that crap that
was the biggest [__] waste of time
when I was playing comedy clubs when
they would hey we got some morning radio
was
fantastic that move tickets those
[__] local radio guys that were the
the the the the [__] show The Morning
Show in that market if you went in there
and you weren't a dick and they liked
you and you [__] you know were cool
self-deprecating you rolled with their
bits and you know and you built a
relationship those [__] people like
you know radio is what got me going
selling
tickets and uh but those morning TV
shows oh my God you would go in there
and there would literally be like
jugglers there's always some sort of
Chef or with some [__] weird it's
candy it's International candy cane day
and to
celebrate candy cane Jane is
here next thing you know you're like
you're like standing behind this [__]
Island I remember that on International
like Pancake Day I was standing there
like I was on the what was that the chop
chopping it
up how dumb is the celebrity
chef the [__] are you doing get back in
the God damn
kitchen you dumb [__] clogs and your
ponytail I know I just described Emerald
not Emerald the other one the other guy
there the [__] uh the Red Baron the
orange crush old pork sausages hands the
well
method [__] is the guy's
name Mario Batali mult moo Mario my
favorite [__] cooking
show okay I don't know what look at you
know what I'm saying
there's a lot of shows that I would
still watch but I don't approve with
what happened afterwards you know
[__] molter Mario The Cosby
Show
uh Partridge Family I don't know I don't
I don't have a third [__] example
whatever what what do you want from me
now that 70
show you
know yeah I could deal with the show
it's what I'm saying um you know I still
have a Mario Bali [__] crockpot thing
whatever you call
it it's called The me too pot in my
house cuz it has the M it says mm I
think on it it's that
[__] it's like that what Ford used to
have trucks the same color that sort of
PE soup green they used to have those in
the early 70s those two-tone ones um the
[__] sixth generation for f100s 150s
and
F250s
um
anyway I think I'm out people I I just
don't think I have anything else to talk
I have so much to talk about that I
can't [__] talk
about um and thank you guys for but I'm
not allowed to do that right now and
that's it so I'd like to spend the final
8 minutes but I'm not going to do it uh
my Boston Bruins beat the [__] Laing
I don't know how they did against the
ducks or the San Jose Sharks I tape
those games I'm going to sit down and
[__] watch those uh heard the Celtics
are looking good my Patriots won you
know whatever two and five I don't give
a [__] you know we'll get there even if
we don't whatever we had a great
run oh we going to win
forever I ran to this Boston guy at the
uh at the wedding and this reset he goes
you know what are you going to do I mean
we had a we had a great run was [__]
unbelievable we got to experience Sports
Bliss and you know I wouldn't say it's
over I'd say there's a
lull you
know I figured the Celtics got to push
through sometime in the next decade who
knows that's a weird game though
basketball
um I don't know why right now but I feel
like I'm at Midas Muffler
I'm just waiting for them to finish the
[__] Muffler this isn't good this
isn't good for the podcast you guys need
to get on with your day all
right do what I'm doing all right try to
[__] lose weight during the holidays
don't start the year with that
[__] as far as like a guy goes you
know you know when your belly connects
to your back tits like your back tits
are right on your [__] hips when that
just becomes a whole circle like you
have like a [__] inner
tube you know what I mean
and the funny thing is if you don't
[__] yank your slacks up then your
ass crack is showing in the back it's
just a bad it's just a sad way to go out
um inadvertently mooning people every
time you try to tie your [__]
shoe um all right that is the podcast
everybody thank you so much for
listening thank you so much for buying
tickets and supporting the projects that
I do uh it means the world to me because
when you do that I get to continue
living this great life
um a telling
jokes um and supporting my beautiful
family so thank you so much um that is
it go [__] yourselves and I will check
in on you on uh on Thursday all right